tell me how that thing works
right
sorry brady
you're looking at um a wonderful little
duck
variously called a wonderful little bird
where is he called the drinking bird the
drinking duck the dunking duck um used
this uh a lot in my for i used to do a
first year module on thermal and kinetic
physics and i used to bring this in at
the start
and
i'd ask how many of you've seen one of
these birds before and maybe 100 odd
hands would go up i'd then say um apart
from on the simpsons and all the hands
would go down so they're a pretty rare
breed they they
crop up all the time anybody who's seen
alien would have seen one of these
towards the start of alien as well
homer used it
to control a nuclear plant disturbingly
but it is just a fantastic demonstration
of so much physics first thing you look
at it and
it appears like a perpetual motion
machine it just keeps going and the
first question you ask well hang on um
first law of thermodynamics says that
we've got to conserve energy where is
the energy source where where how is it
being powered there aren't any batteries
and there aren't any electrical
connections we're not cheating this
water i should also point out um
yeah is at room temperature
and that
that
raises another important question
because the second law of thermodynamics
basically says you can't have a an
engine just working off a single
temperature loosely speaking
and so the question is you've got
generally with any engine you have a hot
reservoir and a cold reservoir on you
and you reject some heat into the cold
reservoir
and
this is a wonderful example of a
sophisticated um heat engine
what uh is also extremely interesting
and i only found out about this recently
is that einstein
couldn't work out how it worked um so he
was he was at a dinner um uh party and
uh one of these little creatures was was
there and einstein spent a lot of time
trying to figure out how how it worked
and apparently couldn't i thought i
thought that was an urban myth but
actually um the
son of the person who invented this
which was a guy called sullivan and he
invented it back in the 40s um
has said that that's absolutely correct
einstein couldn't work out how it worked
i'm not surprised if somebody was to
give this to many physicists including
particularly myself and so how does it
work you go
so
how does it work well if einstein
doesn't i surely feel very early doesn't
it oh well it's interesting phil
moriarty has access to google and a huge
number of resources that einstein
definitely didn't have access to the
other thing
as i said brady is that um i had to
carry out some emergency surgery on it
this morning and actually fix the pivot
but um i'm glad to see that it's back to
working order so we've got the the head
which consists of felt and the important
thing
that you need to do is to get that head
wet so what i did before brady came in
before you come in brady is to put the
head in in the water make sure it's nice
and wet
and then we have this
basically we have a process which is
equivalent to the duck sweating uh
we've got evaporative cooling that means
we get a temperature difference and
that's key now we've got a temperature
difference you can start to see how this
thing starts to act like a heat engine
cools it down and the important thing is
that this blue stuff which colored blue
inside is not water it's actually
something called dichloromethane a
relatively natural quite nasty solvent
the important thing with dichloromethane
is that at room temperature it's got a
very high vapor pressure which means
that there's lots of gas molecules
streaming off from it
and so what happens is when you cool
here
the temperature in the head goes down
and uh the
uh
the dichloromethane vapor condenses in
the head
okay which means that you get a pressure
difference between the head and the
bottom now pressure difference because
there's now a smaller pressure here you
actually um drive uh the
solvent the dichloromethane up through
this inner tube
sorry i didn't mean to hit it and um
that changes because the the solvent is
moving up the dichloromethane is moving
up the tube that changes the center of
gravity the center of gravity moves and
it means that the head pops into the
water
and then what's important this is this
is crucial as it comes around
the bottom end of the tube comes out
momentarily out of the liquid and that
allows a pressure equalization and you
start the cycle all over again
remarkable wonderful wonderful piece of
of physics
you